foreign
it's pretty scary huh hi I'm Stu and if
you're like me you hate this [ __ ]
no video game does the jump scare better
than the original dead space but why are
they so effective
jump scares have been a part of the
horror genre since the very beginning
but more often than not they can feel
like a cheap way to get a reaction out
of an audience
sometimes however there are jump scares
that will stay with the audience long
after the credits roll and we'll have
you checking every corner and keeping
the lights on
before we begin I just want to get some
basic definitions out of the way so we
can be clear on what we're talking about
let's break it down
first I want to talk about horror and
Terror
horror is the feeling of disgust that
usually follows a frightening sight
sound or experience
terror is the feeling of dread and
anticipation before the horrifying
experience
the two so often get lumped together
under the broader horror genre that they
can get mixed up but in Dead Space the
distinction is clear let's show that
Necromorph again
this is horror
[Applause]
this is Terror
and when I talk about a cheap jump scare
I'm really talking about a scare that
has no Terror within the horror of the
jump scare itself I feel like a jump
scare needs to be the catharsis of all
of the terror that has built up before
it it's the terror of an unknown room
the terror of not knowing what's around
the corner they all deserve a scare to
cut the tension and this is where Dead
Space is a
yeah masterpiece
the piece Dead Space never presents you
with a cheap jump scare in 11 hours of
playing I never scoffed at my TV uttered
a oh [ __ ] you or wanted to throw my
controller out the window
well that one I actually did but that
was because of those environmental
puzzles near the end
I did get scared though
a lot
oh my God
that was the logo screen but the reason
these scares and horrifying sites never
felt cheap was because of
[Music]
Dead Space openly communicates to you
how you are going to get scared
Necromorphs always come out of vents
unless they're already mulling around in
the areas you have stepped into you can
chart precisely where they will appear
sometimes even seeing them drop down or
Scuttle along the ventilation of the
ishimura before popping out with the
musical's thing to give you a big hug
the ventilation shafts also burst wide
open when they jump out so you have a
visual marker of where they are coming
from one of the greatest examples of
this communication is during the lead-up
to the Leviathan encounter after leaving
the greenhouses in Hydroponics you'll
enter a door towards food storage and
this happens
At first I felt confused and a little
cheated by this otherwise unexpected
scare but then I realized
I knew this was coming there were these
massive holes ripped out of the ishimura
leading up to Hydroponics which I
assumed to be more spaces for the
regular Necromorphs more specifically
those tentacle-headed ones to crawl out
of I mean that's weird but I thought it
was just more of that environmental
storytelling what I realized is that
wasn't this a scene to get my
imagination going I was being warned
and this comes to the other way that
Dead Space expertly crafts its scares
[Music]
in Dead Space you do a lot of
backtracking in pure metroidvania style
you revisit spaces with new knowledge of
which doors are unlocked and new
abilities to use to Traverse the
ishimura walking back over a corpse I
thought I had chopped up only to hear
the musical sting and watch it rise up
behind me was horrifying and
simultaneously brilliant a jump scare
that changes how you think about your
environment subverts your expectations
and adds to the terror of the game is a
well done jump scare to me also it had
me checking every dead Necromorph just
to be sure that they weren't playing
dead
speaking of subverting your expectations
let's talk about elevators aside from a
close call at the beginning of the game
elevators are a safe space even safer
than most safe rooms in game that is
until you get to the mining decks I
didn't think anything of it I thought it
was just another loading elevator you
know maybe some Whispers or scuttling
around in the vents like normal all of a
sudden in Full Metal Gear Solid fashion
I was surrounded by a group of
Necromorphs after that I was sure not to
let my guard down on any elevator ride
this subversion of the world's rules
allows horror and Terror to actively
feed each other instead of creating a
pipeline where horror can only ever
react to Terror and all this is
bolstered by the design elements of the
original Dead Space the necromorph's OG
design as well as every iteration that
comes up are incredibly well crafted
sound design is also extremely important
the musical sting I keep mentioning sets
your nerves on edge and the combinations
of baby cries animal noises and guttural
spewing I'll make the beasts calls and
screams a horrific encounter in Dead
Space in order to progress through the
story you have to engage with the horror
it has to offer
but here's the thing horror is fleeting
I love this definition by Gothic horror
writer Anne Radcliffe when talking about
the difference between Terror and horror
horror contracts freezes and nearly
annihilates the soul after about chapter
six or seven my whole Dead Space
experience became an exhausting slog
through rooms with the same jump scare
setup the scares were never cheap they
were just expected this pattern of the
same scare room to room really started
to wear me down but what kept me playing
and kept me utterly terrified
were the environments I found myself
more terrified than horrified as the
game went on gurgling walls of alien
biology the greenhouses with the canned
Forest noise the super tight
whisper-filled hallways of the executive
levels these all kept me on edge so that
jump scares were still effective
and even if it overstays its welcome in
the horror Department the terror of each
new environment of the ishimura The
Valor and the colony kept me on the edge
of my seat I don't want to talk too much
about Terror because that's the next
video but I want to say what makes Dead
Space such a fantastic horror genre
experience overall is it combines the
best elements of horror and Terror again
Ann Radcliffe says it better than I ever
could Terror expands the soul and
awakens the faculties to a high degree
of life this Reliance on imagination
anticipation and expansion is what I
love about the horror genre and is
executed so fantastically within the
first dead space but instead of relying
on what makes just dead space terrifying
I want to link it to a section of the
horror genre that seems to be born out
of the internet and taking the indie
horror game scene by storm
the liminal space
sorry that was a cheap one I'm Stu and
if you want more scary content keep it
here at gamespot.com and thank you for
watching